let's let's write Gail some let's write
Gail some material piece of cake
dude I could we could I could knock out
50 times you know like an old lesbian
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola with me
okay let's do the show because I got a
lot of things
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
oh my God
the amount of material you have to cover
week to week is tremendous and then he
taught me a system
but I used oh you saw the system though
right all the all the capital letters
and stuff that I used to Market that was
too confusing for me does it work for
you it's starting to work for me because
now I'm really thinking about it that
way if you say
um where would I find uh that I would be
like ww ft
yeah I feel like that's something you
have to pick up where would I find this
I I couldn't see myself I started doing
word association today I had to say
we're gonna need to catalog all of the
uh
um your inventory and take you know your
missing items or something like that and
take and see what was taken so I Thought
Catalog and then I have to like yeah it
was basically like a game that I played
with it and so I I was thinking oh see
you got my head in a good way that
helped me memorize but the amount of
volume is ridiculous and then he does
something incredible I saw a photograph
remember anything you do yeah
yeah she could tell you
they could if you if you go back and say
a date of their life they could tell you
everything that happened that day
yeah I can't do that I can look at a
line and if I have no pressure it's just
there wow
but I always usually feel a little bit
of pressure do you think that's a gift
do you think it's just having a clear
head or I don't know I think from just
doing theater in school I would count my
lines and it would be like 150 lines in
a play and then I would just go through
and I would just memorize them over and
over and over and I think that just kind
of stuck with me so then doing small
scenes that are you know three pages
long
just is easier
um Gill has a memory of what could you
could remember everything you ate okay
salt shakes
you remember crime statistics yes
really yeah
but about not not just you know he
caught the Night Stalker yeah of course
he was the one that even though he
looked like Linda Ronstadt in the
beginning
yeah he's like he's like if you if
you're alerted of anything I said this
[ __ ] can break into some Blue
Bayou yeah
a [ __ ] little monster like that too
and then uh it was only internal that
this is how crime fighting was back then
here's the guy who said it's it's one
guy and this guy is a serial killer
[ __ ] cannibal taking eyes with them
throwing [ __ ] out inside of people's
houses yeah no DNA and he does a video
and it's only internal to the Sheriff's
Office yeah we didn't not even
computerization was up that well so we
did we made a video down our media
section made copies of it and got it out
to every station so everybody had the
same working information but they had
copies of it wasn't streamed or anything
yeah it's like it's like having a secret
in high school that only your friends
know
most notorious [ __ ] killer stop
telling anybody speaking of fighting I
was always had this question for Gil and
excuse me if you covered it but I heard
a story from sheriffs that these
sheriffs had to go into County and
escort some prisoners out or something
like that and then they were attacked in
there have you ever had anyone try to
take your weapon have you ever been in a
full-on fight to the death
no I've been in fights not while you
were dating nobody got married
once I got the homicide which was in 81
they I didn't have to do that your
fighting days were over yeah no but how
about as a patrol yeah as a patrol cop
I've been I've been in fights uh that
were I don't know that any of them were
defined because because you have a gun I
have a gun on I remember the first time
I used a sap you know just saying you
know that guy guy come running down the
hallway and we had one what's the sap
it's a sap it's a leather about 12
inches length leather filled with lid
this was uh a sap and some guy come
running around I knew you know he's a
badass he come right around the hallway
and I I collared him and I sapped him
right in the head as hard as I could and
the sap went flying so now the fight's
on you know I lost my sap now the
fight's just on and uh but I I won yes
was the step go flying from your hand
because in the carb you were you were
eating candy all the little pocket made
your head is stuck to my head I might
have been eating candy I'm not a sweet
eater burrito there have been queso on
there in Chile but no candy yeah the
jalapeno skin got caught between the sap
in you but so so but that's what that's
what um I mean hand to hand yeah yeah we
were we were hand to hand but you're
wearing a gun are you terrified that
somebody's gonna he's gonna try to take
that or no I I fought I fought dead bang
because I got out of a car one night we
had been in foot pursuit and helicopters
overhead and directed me to the backyard
where this guy's at and it was a cold
night I'm wearing a nylon jacket so I
get out of my car and I run back there
where he's at and I see the guy and we
take him down and I hit him with my
stick because I went first I want to do
he was trying to hide I went to get my
gun and my gun wasn't there
so I think this guy's armed and I don't
know so now the fight is on and I'm
fighting for my life you know and matter
of fact some Sergeant came by and stuck
his hand in there and I swung to hit the
guy with the Baton and he screams he
said be careful get your hand out of the
way then you know I'm taking care of
business so we hooked him up and I went
back and what had happened when I got
out of the car when I was running my
sleeve
got hooked on the butt of my gun
and knocked it out of my holster oh wow
so that was the last time I wore a
jacket on patrol
I did it without afraid to lose my gun
what about other anything any other
fights like multiple fights not really
because it doesn't seem like you're able
to I'm big the the the you weren't
afraid that since you weren't wearing
your jacket that if you rolled into like
a crime scene that the guys that were
there would go mad that shares got some
nice stats
let's introduce our guests here
um El Madrigal is uh actor comedian from
San Francisco yes very talented was on
The Daily Show uh an incredible writer
brilliant mind and comedy anxiety like a
[ __ ] yeah I'm [ __ ] aware this
battle looks cool on the outside he's
all convoluted on the inside Matt
Shively is a tremendous actor star of
Lopez versus Lopez uh this body
transformation that he's morphed
literally from from Mrs Doubtfire and
the pilot to man candy from the second
episode on you were chubby and the pilot
dude I lost 18 pounds between episode
one about to look like Miss that fire oh
my mom used to work for you
he's like Jeremy dumpfire Jeremy and uh
but but um you were 18 pounds and uh
heavier but were you when you audition
were you preparing for anything were you
you're right on vacation I always
stopped drinking between uh January and
the end of March because of pilot season
because I bloat really because he's a
[ __ ] good actor no no no
I want to stop drinking that that's why
I stopped drinking because I blew no I
just I've I've
no because I try to lose all of the
holiday wait so I was like I I actually
had lost like five pounds six pounds
leading up to the pilot itself and then
once we got picked up I was like okay I
guess I could try a little bit and I
just I just stopped incredible man this
guy this guy I will say this you know
people that want to be an actor and and
uh are out there I would say that uh
don't ever think that you can't do it I
mean because everybody comes from
everywhere around the world and they
become everything that they want to be
you know people that want to be you know
police officers and detectors can do
great things but if you say to yourself
man you know I'll never I don't know how
to do it I'll never know how to do it
there's way more information now at your
fingertips you have a phone I mean
whatever right it's all there you can
ask anything of any question to tell you
so you know
we had a guy like we we looked at maybe
like a hundred and fifty maybe 200 guys
maybe I think actors all kinds of actors
and actors that you've seen and known
you know for his part really popular
great actors and then settled for math
so so even even guys like you know if if
you've had some success and then you
know your show ends you know that's just
turning that page like you never go back
to that page again it's like what you
know if if it never had success then
they'll say oh you were on that show
what was the name of it and it's like oh
yeah then as time goes they stop asking
you know what show it was and then
everybody's out there and you might uh
see a guy and go wow that guy is really
good and they're really good but they're
just not right like you know there's a
look and there's a style so we thought
uh that the quenching character was
going to be more of a of a nerdy you got
like a nebish guy and then we found the
guy that was friends with somebody that
Maya knows and and I know him to the
friend of the family and that guy was
good that guy was good very good he and
he ran against other actors and he stood
out and NBC and Universal said you know
we don't like that guy we don't think
he's the right type that's not the
person that we see in this part and
we're like [ __ ] man do we fight for that
dude or do we say well I mean they're
gonna ultimately make the last decision
it's not my show it's not it's not
anybody's show it's not so it's their
decision they're hiring the people and
we saw Matt
and I think you were on vacation weren't
you no I had actually I was working in
the keys you were the keys yeah and the
day I landed was I got that email saying
that I was meeting again because I had
already gone out like three or four
times for it oh without a scene I well I
read with Maya and like a month prior oh
wow and I I remember getting it and I I
got the size I was like oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna book this this is I this is
totally me and then I went like three
separate times didn't work and then the
moment I landed in the keys is when I
got the the email saying about that for
the producers and I was like well [ __ ] I
don't have anything to do it so I had to
like tape my phone up against a wall in
a hotel and just hope for the best plus
they had just sent outsides that day
where the character was half Mexican and
they kept making comments about it about
him being half Mexican and he's like
well George I am Mexican and I was like
well [ __ ] this is yeah that's a trip
yeah and so luckily this is where your
memorization skills come in and you're
able to tape a phone up against the wall
people don't realize how hard it is to
self tape and do these auditions it is
now because they're not doing any
in-person
um you know meetings anymore and casting
sessions
yeah you have to be your own Tech person
I think by the way my favorite story
about all of this was the moment we
finished the pilot in front of the live
audience my parents came down and you
met my parents and you started telling
them the story about how you were like
oh we found these two guys they were
great we really wanted them the studio
said no and they were like okay and then
you're like no no but then there was
this other guy that we really really
loved that I was like rooting for but
the studio wasn't down and so we had to
move and I was like just tell them that
I was the choice from the time
disappears my parents here and just say
it was always me but how much you kind
of go [ __ ] everybody he was asleep baby
he came back look at his car key was
like hey you're in
I mean you know how I am you already
spent six months with me I don't give I
don't [ __ ] throw compliments
um oh I write them all down I have so
many different persons I know I have a
lot of different personalities yes you
do
um this one's different than others but
but you really are I mean I've worked
with you know some actors you can like
and some you don't like and I've been
fortunate to have you know you saw the
people from the first show yeah but uh I
hold you in high esteem well I
appreciate that because I think you're
an incredibly talented guy funny as [ __ ]
man dude and also what about we did the
[ __ ] Junior acrobats in the backyard
dude dying
um the the the preparation is inspiring
like again I'm I'm not even like
I do throw compliments around but
they're deserving because you and
selenis are did I say that right yeah
[Laughter]
very difficult name uh what am I the
[ __ ] judge of the spelling yeah like
uh yes I say it wrong all the time I I
don't even want to say the name we have
an actress on the show who's amazing as
well and she [ __ ] brings it and uh I
mean I I just this group
um is is it's pretty inspiring I've told
you this like you made me I like and
again I I really want to be great in
every single line and have it I have to
come in and hit homers and
um because you know you're dealing with
a limited amount of space but then
um it so yeah but you show up you're all
[ __ ] marijuana you show up under the
influence but that's all right alleged
that is not true I'm a method actor I
put myself in the space you do
um I really try are you still wearing
your red beanie or not I haven't paid
attention I am non-story scene they
change the color occasionally on me but
yeah this is the longest I've seen you
without a beanie on oh really in person
yeah yeah crazy
um I I love it I think again that's why
um I'll talk about it on Monday when I
wrapped
oh what don't shake your head I'm
telling you you
have moments with one of your
personalities you're very are good about
talking about feelings and you're very
like
um I could see you getting sappy and uh
you were uh you're just like me that's
Robert that's another guy no you're
gonna emotional about this stuff you
know how much I love this group and
that's what that's where all that came
from no no no no no that's not true if
you were paying attention to all the
scripts you would know
that you know you might well you you
know your character was gonna you know
we're gonna all of our lines are gonna
end in a couple of weeks I think yeah no
I know that I know that I know I know
that but I don't know I just we went
from the premiere which again Lopez this
is Gary Gilmore was executed in Utah he
showed less drama than you did rapping
your last scene that [ __ ] just
said let's do it and you're like I just
want to tell everyone this is to be fair
that guy knew it was going to be the end
yeah he was aware I'm firing squad
I was legitimately uh Missing you're
gonna miss everybody so it was very
sincere
it's lame we came back it's not like
we did something in your personality and
your thing family like abandonment no
something in there not even abandonment
of people leaving maybe or maybe you're
literally coach got in a car accident
never came back I if you wanted if we
were you guys really want to know like
uh I always felt really as a little you
want to give them the okay go ahead and
then we'll give them the test of the
thing please I always felt really as a
little kid sad at Christmas
and I know exactly where it comes from
and I still sometimes like I like
watching my kids but I always get sad at
Christmas because my brothers and had
Godfathers that would show up with these
big gifts and like I and I got like a
remember they used to do a book of life
savers
like you if at Christmas time they got
the variety of Lifesavers when you're a
little kid and it was like in a little
book I got that
and then um like and you know my parents
bought me gifts but it was like
Christmas Eve was a big deal in our
house who was your godfather my uncle
John who do you like yeah
Lifesavers he didn't even bring
Lifesavers it was like he he didn't
bring hey you still living no they all
passed away did you have a uh
relationship with them and that wasn't
about material
yeah
no it's true I did it was nice but
anyway because yeah I was a little baby
about it but
um I feel like this I think where that
came from is I've been on a lot of TV
shows that haven't I've never had this
feeling with a group like this and
that's why I know it's special and I was
like what is I'm going away I'm gonna
start crying
no I was [ __ ] a normal camera people
weren't there so they're like all right
they're like Al good job no no no no no
but but yes I mean and you see how much
I talk to everybody too what the [ __ ] is
that man I'm just naturally like I've
always known everybody's name on set I
can tell you every single wardrobe
because that's one of the reasons why
those shows haven't succeeded
walks in and walks out yeah I know
there's something to that isn't there
yeah I mean yeah just because there's a
lot of being let down it's not that I'm
unfriendly it's not that I'm unfriendly
but I have a you know I have a I have a
drive that I just I go yeah and I do my
thing and I I you got the timer I go I
go back out and I go back out but you're
also on another team but I think you're
you operate up here you're another it's
just that there's you know there's just
what do they call them a Vietnam's FN
fngs [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] new guy
like nobody makes any
um relationship with anybody in the
first part of the show yeah because
they're not going to be around exactly
so in a sense you're I I learned from
the other show over the first show that
I would just go and really be very
compartmentalized about where I would go
and just do it and come back and do it
and come back I seriously go and I'm
just talking to the [ __ ] boom guy
I study the board and learn everybody's
names I go in between I've got you
multiple times three inches from that
board faces because you're like
everybody liked me and all that you want
everybody to like you I just I think I
don't know so what changes when we do
season two what changes on your end
nothing you don't get any closer
no not that I'm distant but I just so
our relationship right now this is as
deep as it goes
uh is it deep well it's it's as deep but
we're very respectful of each other
right yes yeah
I I don't know where it comes from I'd
have always been like this I cried
yourself to sleep as an adult
[Laughter]
give them the detective test how to
learn that's isn't that a good one
though I I miss my calling
[Laughter]
I should have been a people yeah
oh that's his fault
I you talk about uh if I ask him a
question what their response is going to
be what kind of yeah yeah yeah okay okay
all right all right all right here's
what the detectives use on suspects and
people under interrogated if if there
are three basic kind of people out there
so if I ask you right now
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind
about your godfather Uncle Johnny what's
the first thing you remember about it
motorcycle motorcycle he's a visual man
because now I know but by people are
basically well let me let me ask you
Matt
what's the first thing that crosses your
mind when you remember thinking about
your grandmother
a big remote
a big remote for I just remember the
older she got the bigger the remote guy
okay now see both of them are are visual
because people 99 99 of people in the
world are either visual kinesthetic or
audio so if I sit there and say what do
your first thing come to me about your
uncle uh him saying I'm sorry I didn't
get you the gift that you wanted you can
still hear his voice or you can hear me
yelling at you at your dad because her
brother and he's fighting you're an
audio person and same thing with you you
know you're either you either love oh my
grandmother she was so sweet I loved her
so much you're kinesthetic so what we do
what I did was then by knowing ask you a
few
questions just find out what kind of
person you are then I will gauge the
questions I'm going to ask you about the
case
on the type person you are
is it you know whether it be a witness a
suspect or anything what did you see
what did you hear what did that guy
sound like you know you can't you don't
remember what he looked like but what
did he sound like
oh you sound like Samuel Jackson
sounded like George Lopez yeah it makes
a lot of sense and so that's what we did
we and I'm an and I'm an auditory guy
I'm not a visual is there a percentage
of who I think more people are visual
than auditory I really don't know I
never kept statistics so so people that
are out there and if they if they have
an interaction with a police officer or
a detective are they being monitored
from the time that the the law
enforcement person sees that person no
most cops don't even think of think like
that it's Advanced you know what should
be come on for a while and you go
through a lot of training you do a lot
of stuff ecology you learn this stuff on
so street cops all know this stuff you
know seasoned detectives will and they
may not know it I remember going through
a class uh analytical interviewing
and they said at the end of the first
session that I was uh unconsciously
conscious
and that means I knew everything they
were trying to teach but I didn't know
how I didn't know why I knew it it just
came to me like imagine well that's
after years and years of doing this [ __ ]
so I knew what to do but I never put a
name to it and so now years and years a
year you put names to it and you did
they still do good cop bad cop yeah yeah
because I think most most people who
would be asked questions by a police
officer they're not uh hardened or they
they're gonna really let you let them
talk right that there's a good good
cutback cup only works with fish new
guys you know that haven't been around
the block haven't been arrested don't
have crime record you know that that
good cop bad company yeah uh other than
that you know and I never like to be the
bad cop
it's much easier to get somebody to talk
to if you treat them decently when you
were growing up
was there anybody in your family that
was an actor was there anybody that was
in theater anybody that was an artist or
anything like that no that's always been
the craziest my mom is always saying
like she doesn't know where I got it
from because I have nobody in my family
but your mom is very extroverted
sure she's very she's she's very happy
about his mom but she's I just met his
mom but I don't know can you give us a
couple of examples she's a trip but
she's she's extroverted she's loud she's
the craziest person in the world when
she says she's like I don't like people
around so she just bought a a house in
North Carolina that's away from
everything she doesn't want to know
anybody who doesn't want to see anybody
but she's also the exact same person
that when we go to a restaurant whoever
is sitting around us in a vicinity she's
going to talk to every one of them and
I'll look down at my phone I'll look
back up and she's over talking to a baby
two two tables down asking what you
ordered and then in the same breath that
night will say I don't like people I
don't like to talk about like be around
people and I'm like that doesn't make
any sense to me I know you get it well
she said she's like I just don't think
people really like me and I said well if
you don't think people like you why do
you approach them if you think that they
don't like you then why are you talking
to them I do that all the time yeah I
talk I talk to people and I go oh man
you're such a [ __ ] idiot why'd you
say that why do you like it in my head I
have like I'm just like oh dude you just
you put your foot in your mouth
I don't know you were like that yeah I I
I I really always have been like and and
so uh super nice to everybody want to
treat everybody the exact same way
garbage man you know whatever you know
lowest person Sammy A.D to you know I
you know Bruce or Katie or anybody uh
running the shows same exact treatment
and like oh he's everybody and then
regret for being so [ __ ] talkative as
well in the car on the way back yeah
shut the [ __ ] up man all right so so so
she's and that's a little bit of a
counter huh counter like you wanna she
bought a house I physically bought a
house where she could be away from
people
but maybe she says I only want to be
with you on my terms
like I want to have my time alone and if
I want to engage in conversations I'll
go to a restaurant fear and controlling
sounds like somebody who wants to be in
control oh uh which is weird because I
think for most of her life she wasn't in
control so maybe that's the reason
because she's doing that she controls
her environment she wants a house all by
herself but yeah when she goes over here
she wants to be in control she wants to
talk to people at her convenience yeah
that's interesting my favorite thing to
do in my life is well I've done it a
couple times play golf solo and uh and
also
um puts around my house and fix it by
myself with airpods and just yeah you
want to be but yeah okay he wants to be
alone yeah see I'm the opposite I hate
beating being alone
but I also have a hard time talking to
people just one-on-one I'm great in a
group of people and I can keep turn it
on at any time but the moment I get
one-on-one with somebody I lock up I
don't know if you've ever known Mr way
different that somebody would be great
in a group of people like be the the guy
bringing people together and then
one-on-one can't talk I just love people
I I really do I love people
I love that quote for the underdog those
those need help you're telling me you've
never been at a party or anything like
that and you're like I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here you don't have any
social anxiety like I wouldn't even go
to the party how about that okay because
I go to some of these like if you go to
like a pre-emmy party or one of the
agency like that I'll look around and
look and I go look at my wife and go we
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here I can't
handle this do you compare yourself to
other people in there I don't know I
don't think so I know a lot of people I
I don't know what's going on I just know
we gotta go
I can only be here for a very medicated
no you smoke the little little thing the
little surfboard yeah surfboard every
now and then every now and then or not
every not constantly
um how long your mom and dad been
married
20 years it's my stepdad about 20 years
old yeah
um my parents divorced when I was five
and then she remarried six years later
do you think that their parent do you
think that them get into divorce made
you want to be an actor like to be
accepted kind of I it's funny you said
that because I literally was talking
about it like six months ago I was like
I I got into acting because I think I
wanted attention yes genuinely that's
right I remember in fourth grade being
in the play and laying down on the stage
at the beginning of the play and there
was an audience looking at me in my head
looking back on it it was like a
thousand people but I think it was maybe
a hundred and I just remember being like
Oh my God they're all looking at me this
is what I have to do did you feel it
turn the light on did you feel it
did you feel it kind of feel you here
like a like oh yeah it was it was the
overwhelming sense of just like oh my
God this is what I want to do forever
and then you know watching television
watching movies and stuff like that
seeing Jim Carrey seeing Shia LaBeouf at
the time like things like that I was
like oh my God I want to entertain the
way that these people entertain
and then it was so it was a mixture of
the wanting the attention but then also
just like loving that you can go and
pretend to do all of these things and
get to have this like amazing time
that's not real and then go and do
another one but also but also you
haven't you at that point you hadn't
acted yet so you don't know what
infrastructure set up in Hollywood or in
place no no no I was I was one of the
ones that went to like
and spent four or five thousand dollars
for commercial classes
I think we might just block his name
that's the one word where if you suck
your their dick say you didn't get you
on a movie of the week they still owe me
a movie
they go in there it's almost like what
was that thing where you go in there and
you go hey the phone's free then they
get coverage you got a case everything's
after that a thousand dollars like you
go in there oh we went in for it was for
a Pepsi commercial and we got there and
it wasn't a Pepsi commercial it was like
a a tutorial for what auditioning for
Pepsi commercial would be and then a guy
would come out and look around and then
point at you and bring you in with your
parent and be like you should sign up
for classes you should do this and this
and this it's going to be this much do
it and so you know they would only pick
like five or ten of those kids and the
rest would leave but they just rope you
into paying all this money and doing
these things and that you know the that
movie me Earl and the dying you know uh
RJ Seiler I worked with him on I'm dying
up here and his stories this kid was
walking
in the mall in Florida
and that's they had one of those things
set up in the mall where it's like
Talent executive here and seriously a
lady picks up the phone and says I found
him oh my God and hangs up and he gets
me Earl and the dying girl
like in Den career just the guy takes
off but so it's got to be like real at
some point but
it seems like a scam sure would you
would you say that
they helped you or did not is there
something connected to the things that
you got as an actor I would say the only
thing that it helped me with was like
once you had signed up for those classes
you were in the system and once a month
they would do an agent showcase and you
would go you could go in and you could
do your own monologue or something for
an agent and then you would get an agent
so that was the only thing that came
from that was the fact that I ended up
getting an agent through them it was a
terrible agent at the time I did I mean
I had two different agents before I
actually had an agent who got me stuff
that so it was just somebody who says
I'm an agent yeah and I'm working with
Robert Bowers yeah pretty much hilarious
yeah you know I went through some Stress
Management we were talking about what
made you go over here I went through the
stress management and the Thomas himself
hypnosis what Stress Management where uh
through the department in Chinatown
through through three years
all this pressure from the homicide
investigations you know everything was
building up so they wanted me to go to
the Stress Management they did part of
this was self-hypnosis so they teach you
they taught me how you walk down these
steps and you get to the bottom and so
you count backwards from 10 you go down
you open this door and you're anywhere
you want to be
where you're comfortable where you're
there's your comfort zone and what was
your comfort zone right it was in a park
where my dad my mom my family all around
I'm just sitting with my back up again
just start crying if you kept talking
about it no no no because it was good it
was good it was how it was my happy
place oh quick and then I I sat there
and I said is it is it wrong to have
more than one place to go to oh and she
said no not at all do you have another
play I said yeah so I went back down
when I get down to the bottom I open the
door and there I am I'm on the second
floor Landing of a ballroom full of
people and they're waiting for me to get
down there and I'm just going to go
they're all my friends they're waiting
for me I'm gonna interact with all of
them they were there waiting for me and
I felt comfortable that was my comfort
zone being around people so it was both
sides either by myself around my family
or being Thrust out with a bunch of
people and I I was comfortable leave the
place interesting
interesting and in school um you played
you play baseball School
I started my freshman year playing
softball I mean playing no no no no no I
started playing baseball ladies what was
your first time and as they were cutting
cutting players last day of cuts I got
cut uh freshman baseball and the coaches
man you get Cut in freshman baseball and
the coach told me he says son he says
I'm sorry he says you know you can hit
good he says you're I was a catcher he
says you're great behind a plate he says
but I'm building this team on speed and
son you ain't got no speed
how about that I gotta build that team
on speed if they're not talking about
the pressure in high school I got cut
from freshman football and a team that I
think
told everybody yes and I thought it must
have been a mistake I don't know what
happened I was so I wanted to play
football so bad and I was so sad I rode
my bike down to the school on Saturday I
looked at the list again damn do you see
chap cried myself today so I didn't cry
I I felt bad I was embarrassed but I I
didn't cry I think that's what made me
funny I think that from then on I was
always like I again friends with
everybody I remember running for student
body Treasures yeah
[Music]
um and then I
won there were 1300 kids in our school
I got 1200 of the votes
um wow and uh the other kid transferred
I got a hundred and scared him out of
school dude the vice principal grab me
he goes hey man he goes I've been doing
this a long time I just want to show you
something he goes no one's ever done
this what the [ __ ] uh do you think that
was your Peak what's that that was your
I was salutatorian I gave a speech
that's what made me want to do stand-up
comedy is like no but did you you want
to do politics did you want to do I just
want to do I just knew I needed to do
something because I got cut from all
these sports teams I didn't I wasn't I
was looking for activities I was like
Jason Schwartzman and Rushmore that
movie where he's got in all the clubs
yeah I was the worst possible student
but I was in every Club I I wrote every
single rally that they put on had we
killed
um I was telling guys I had a clipboard
I'm like go now Gene hit it I like
[ __ ] you're on uh I couldn't tell him
guys it was always like God damn yeah
what's going on there all right dude I I
didn't have any other skills
to say how would you describe that
what's that person I was horrible at
math well I was I was a part of that
person I did all the I wrote all the
rallies I hosted all the rallies I did
all that stuff I but I I just I think I
genuinely just liked people watching me
at the time and like getting a reaction
was everything so it was like and you
were cute as a button I would I would
assume I mean she still lives
10 years old for a long time yeah long
time I'm 32 now and I'm like that's
still holy [ __ ] like a little marionette
everybody
am I the youngest person to be on this
show how long did you what was your
first gig then
uh well so that's where I did get lucky
my mom didn't want me to be an actor I
didn't live here though that's a thing I
grew up in Covina which is only about 30
minutes east from here sure so I I was
pretty much from here
um we moved a lot you know up until I
was like 10 and then it was from 10 on
it was Covina but my mom never wanted me
to be an actor because the rejection and
stuff so it took a long time for me to
convince her to let me do it and when
she tell you no like she would say do
your two or more conversation I'm not
joking with you my mom you would say no
Matt no I'm not gonna do it you're not
gonna do it she said it's too much I
can't bear it to this day if you were to
ask my mom what she'd want me to do she
wants me to work at Taco Bell down the
street and that's a legitimate thing
like she I think my mother would love if
I still lived at home and worked at Taco
Bell that's her go-to well you can
always come work at Taco Bell down the
street I'm like yeah but I'm here now
yeah but you know just in case does work
out go work talk about
Covina that's not far from the VFW
we got to go to the VFW and hang out
with them there's a lot of people for
you to talk to there
I'll be nice to everything hey so so
yeah so
um
I guess you needed her to drive you to
an audition right yeah
she finally gave in when I was like 13.
and that's that was and it was years of
saying same tour it was it was years of
saying no and then seventh grade she
finally said yes that's when I went to
did all that but I didn't really book
anything until like four months before I
graduated high school and that was when
I got lucky because I was going to do
anything I had [ __ ] going on like I
wasn't going to college I wasn't doing
anything
it's almost like the universe said
I know that if I don't give you
something right now you're gonna go do
something else and I can never get you
back to this place where I have your
full attention so the show that I ended
up booking I knew the cast director well
I went in and I told her straight up I
said this the last time you're gonna see
me and she said were you quitting and I
said no I'm gonna book this and if I
don't I'm done and hilariously enough it
was a Nickelodeon show and I ended up
being on that for a really long time and
right before I went into it
I was on a show called True Jackson VP
on Nickelodeon and I
actually was on that show as well for an
episode I played a security guard
Peruvian security guard with Johnny
Sanchez two dim wooded security guards
he sprayed me in the face with mace yeah
we maced his ass what was it instead of
Hairspray don't know a little Silly
String or something it's probably water
it was probably water oh so you guys
so the the day that you guys showed up
for work you're like hey well I saw his
name on the thing I was like holy [ __ ]
I've worked with him he was on True
Jackson yeah which is crazy because you
go on Steve tablowski played my dad he
played a dad to the other guy on that
rad was the ad of that show yeah whoa
yeah so I actually had there's a few
people how many episodes did you guys do
56
we did 56 in less than two years it's
not a lot yeah because they had to shoot
as many as possible before we grew up
because the girls were still young but I
was 18. it was Andrew Jackson Keke
Palmer from nope
well she's in no she was in the movie
with Jordan Peele movie that just came
out she's she's great she hosts uh
password with Jimmy Fallon on NBC and uh
oh yeah yeah
um and uh
who else was it we had Greg proops was
like the owner of the the company uh
yeah Paul F Tompkins was on a bunch of
episodes that's interesting because the
showrunner was loved stand-up comedy
well it was and it was during the
writers strike of 08 so all of our
writers were Network writers it was like
people who wrote just shoot me and all
this stuff and so like all the writers
were Network writers and had a lot of
connections so if you go and look at all
of our guest stars like we had a lot of
crazy guest stars on that show which was
not normal for Nickelodeon who's on the
show uh we had I mean we had Will
Smith's daughter and he was there the
whole time we had Andy Richter we had
um
Jesus who else do we have
we I felt like every week it was so many
different times yeah yeah
um
Melissa Roush I think might have done a
Melissa Roush
I'm not sure is your wife in the
business as well my wife is a teacher
school teacher I'm a one headshot per
household family your girlfriend's
Insurance actress she's actually yeah
she left today off to Vancouver to shoot
something for two weeks two weeks yeah
will you how was that man how is that uh
dating an actress like a working actress
well it's tough because when you're both
actors and you're both not working it it
can affect your relationship because you
both don't you know it's that whole like
you know they're not going to leave you
so you take out all your problems on
them and so then when you're both not
working you're both just having problems
with each other and you have to keep
reminding each other that it's like oh
no it's because we're not working and
we're trying to work yeah but it's tough
because it's not a solid it's not the
most solid foundation to
everybody's always you know when are we
gonna have kids I'm like dude I don't
even know if I'm gonna have a job next
week so like I gotta like there's no
security
start crying
there's no security so how are you so
you know you can't there's no there's no
I'm gonna have a nine to five from here
on out it's it's I'm hoping yeah yeah
okay so so Christ can I interject and
say shut up Aaron real quick
I know I'm way over the [ __ ] the line
so so so
um when people are doing stuff like that
you know and uh there's a lot of uh
uncertainty I would say uncertainty in a
relationship you know because you know
maybe somebody wants to be a teacher and
then one household is working or maybe
they're both working they both work
part-time and then they manage to keep
it together you know or sometimes uh you
know a woman will say you know well I
would I kind of want a guy that's a
little bit more secure and what his
future is going to be you're not in a
stand-up comedian or an actor you know
so
um well they can't ever pull that car
because of the fact that we're both
they're both in there yeah so it's great
yeah man that's the plus side but it's
funny I mean a week ago we were talking
she's like I just haven't worked and I'm
I'm losing it and I'm like listen the
rest of the year it's a wash it's all
good the moment she said it was all good
woke up the next morning got an offer to
do a movie in Vancouver making more
money than she has in a few years like
it's it's that's the whole thing about
the business mood immediately changes
like oh 100 it's like all of a sudden
we're happy again it's like at what
point do we say you know
um we're gonna move on to are you guys
does an actor does an actor look at the
end of of a possibility of his life as
an actor or does he think he's gonna be
active for life I gotta say I think
about you
when you were on the radio all the time
like I I because you were like you you
were like I'm out of here I'm not doing
this anymore you were like I'm not going
to do you went to the radio no more
acting I'm not gonna give up on the
George Lopez show and that's when it all
happened right is that that's right so
I just know I need to stay the course
but I have been like you know you just
like I I'm trying to persevere as much
as I can and uh it's tough dude it's
it's hard especially I got a kid in
college did you give any of these
wonderful traits to your kids
yeah
yeah I know but kids have something I
mean I did my son has a tremendous
amount of anxiety he does yeah okay so
um and I'm worried about it you know
it's like because anxiety is I I you
know I [ __ ] with anxiety I make fun of
it but I'm really just as a comedian
making fun of it I know it's something
very very serious and the worst part I
think is maybe culturally like where we
come from where somebody would have it
and then people like me would make fun
of it and then you know The Battle Turns
a [ __ ] doorknob 89 times before you
can go outside
right I'd never gone to therapy I asked
Matt are you okay with me to mention
this like yeah yeah yeah I asked Matt I
go I need to talk to somebody because a
lot I don't know if you know there's a
lot of comedians been dying I've I've
got a lot of comic friends that have
been croaking left and right and one was
kept coming up in my memories just it
was that can you say Jack knight uh
young black comic who I worked with a
lot yeah very young and very talented
and you know how your iPhone does
memories and in your iPhone
haunting me just different pictures
non-stop you know your iPhone does
memories yeah haunting me
dude I like but doesn't it
just it got that one got me that one but
in a way isn't it saying let's enjoy
these times let's enjoy them sure yeah
they're just like they put music I'm
more surprised that you haven't gone to
therapy the fact that you would like
I've never done a great guy everybody
should go to therapy I thought I was
weak and didn't have the time and like
have you been in therapy [ __ ] no [ __ ]
you when I grew up every time you've
never gone to therapy so even after all
like the stuff you said that dude he was
in Vietnam I mean I do got it you got it
I guess that's crazy I grew up with
basically him as my dad
you wouldn't even think about it well
it's not that I that culturally you
wanted to be a comedian if you get if
that [ __ ] if we if in here we
said Gil there's 15 minutes of material
that you can use in here that well he'd
be out there at the haha Cafe he would
be uh Romo not Momo
I I was asking
but I I'm not looking for anything
because I told I asked my wife you know
and we've been married a day and a half
it'll be uh the 26th of this year of
next month will be 52 years 52. so I
asked her I said what do you think if I
get on stage and I'll do a little comedy
there and she didn't she really wasn't
excited about it you know what you know
what I think you should do it man you
know you're a writer right yeah let's
let's write Gail some let's write Gail
some material piece of cake
dude I could we could I could knock out
50 times you look like you know like an
old lesbian
I know
I know you might have bought some potted
plants from me
[Laughter]
I mean so I mean you really would right
like like I mean
it's a beaut isn't it
um like let's say because
isn't it a beautiful thing to like be
introduced on the show and you run out
there and you walk out there and that
audience is there and through your own
two eyes like you see all of the things
that you've seen other people do
Seinfeld and you've seen you know uh
Desi Arnaz he's seen you know the way
they do backstage where they were the
Audio I mean news radio I saw feel heart
all that stuff that you go out there and
it's where it's the Mount Rushmore of of
sitcoms where uh cast is introduced and
they all walk out there and everybody's
introduced isn't it the most incredible
thing to perform in front of a live
audience and be introduced I really
think that the reason my wife her
biggest against not because I'm gonna
get in trouble or do anything it's just
that it's like kill you get enough
attention you know I go out you know I
saw your mom yeah I speak you get enough
exercise at school I'm a speaker and and
so I showed her I was in Las Vegas five
thousand people in attendance and I I go
out there and I speak
it's put on by oxygen it's a crime con
and so they 45 minutes and I mean it's
all done professionally they're really
they've got big clock right there to
counter down how I'm doing crime comment
so I I speak and I'm done
first I got a standing ovation oh my God
and people are standing and I'm saying
oh [ __ ] hold on I get my vid I get my
camera and I said let me I want to film
this let's capture this and so all said
and done I come back
and they send me a professional copy of
the video
and I'm watching it online and so I said
dear you want to see this you know so
she watches with me and when she was
done
I said what do you think she says well
it was all right but why do you have to
make fun of me
because I talk about her while I'm doing
straight stuff but I've also learned
that from a professor that I had
who required more work than any
Professor I ever had he used humor as a
vehicle to get his point across because
when you're funny you guys
people are listening because they don't
want to miss a joke they don't want to
miss the funny part so they're paying
attention to you and then you get that
big raw laugh so when I sit there and
say yeah my wife moved out August the
8th and she and I ain't coming back
until he's in custody and that was a
true she moved out of the house took the
kids with her she's gone
so I said so now I tell her at least
once a year hey we got the wrong guy
just to see her move on again that must
kill yeah yeah and and so everybody
laughs and she said but why do you have
to make fun of me
and so how would you get paid to do this
I got a name for you if you're a big
comedian what's that Juan candy
you know I had a nephew he used to think
I was John Candy he said he looked just
like God
but uh um but I think yeah you see how
he wants I bet but the but the perfect
interjection of fact and fiction is
stand up
yeah it's making it is things making fun
of things that you can telling a good
story and like with Jeffrey Dahmer I
said you know Mexicans can't be
cannibals because when we get menulo we
take the Pata
you know you
and if you're telling the truth it's
easy it's easy to tell the truth when
you're lying you have to make [ __ ] up
and then because this is my new one if
she don't eat menudo she won't eat a
noodle
[Music]
and you can have that one man
but I mean you know so so I think in a
sense people want to be accepted in
whatever term it doesn't matter whether
it's 150 000 people or 15 people five
people oh the feeling that you get when
you do new stuff and it kills yes oh
this is dude I mean I remember like
walking up oppositively you know like
just skip a message like hey hey hey how
are you I love it so much I was I did
stand up one time and it I've never felt
a hive like that in my life not even
acting or no no I did I went up at the
haha at an open mic one time and my
buddy convinced me and I was like sure
how did you prepare the stuff did you
say I'm gonna off my top dude I have
I've got like 150 things in my like
notes under stand up and I could just
basically
give them a go give him the guild hey
welcome yeah I'm not thin I'm not pretty
why don't you do it let's do all let's
all do stand up let's you know I was
thinking about today I was like it'd be
so funny if we could just as a show just
go on the road everybody doing I think
mine did stand up too some she writes
jokes so yeah you know mine's just there
well mine's [ __ ] up too man she's got
all kinds of anxiety too like oh [ __ ]
weird and deep breaths I didn't take a
deep breath till I was in my bucket 40s
you know everybody's like
dude I want to take a [ __ ] deep
breath the [ __ ] somebody said [ __ ]
Chicago
take a deep breath
[ __ ] rib cage your [ __ ] ribs are
touching each other you're so so [ __ ]
riddled I become such a [ __ ] Chicago
they're all they're all [ __ ] wound up
yeah they're all hard their bodies are
all hard I woke up in that mummification
[ __ ] seven years old you you
sleep through the night
uh yeah since I just started wetting the
bed
I woke up at 3am
3 A.M 3 A.M is the [ __ ] witch's hour
which one hour too just going haunted
house
what the [ __ ]
I have to take a sleep gummy to go to
sleep every single night or I will wake
up at three o'clock in the morning like
but I think everybody does that do you
try expository I smoke
what's the phone number for the show
again
because we haven't used it
uh
do you still take gummies to sleep
I haven't had to lately
I haven't had because I ran out I got a
bunch of stuff I'm about bringing some
stuff all right yeah I have a lot a lot
of stuff and gummies will put me out is
it what is it do we still haven't 3 1843
533 1843 818 yeah it's on the screen
right there okay
family of oils that's good
you know if you're out there you know
um call us and leave a message of what
you take before you sleep if anybody
takes a sedative or what kind of
sedative or if you take Unison or what
or you or if you go to sleep naturally
which yeah that's what I want to know
let's see if yeah I just you don't have
to be a long message just say you know I
use this I go to sleep or my wife
doesn't seems like a baby yeah have you
ever taken something like ambien or
anything no no no no I I try to Knocked
Up you haven't taken like any
medications at all I really don't like
pills one bit well that's why you're all
[ __ ] up you gotta take something can I
ask why I don't know I've always never
wanted to like I take a cholesterol
medication and that's about it that's it
but you've never taken like Xanax you've
never taken anything for travel like my
doctor because I oh horrible travel
anxiety
um
this was Love is Blind on Netflix
[Laughter]
I have a hard time making it through
through the airport with my family so we
figured out a routine because I was so
used to traveling as a stand-up comic
that I totally no I'm
trying I always tell you the truth but I
love that but what seems so natural and
so complicated
I'll always tell everybody the truth I'm
not gonna like it so I um had a hard
time traveling with my family because it
stresses me out I needed my dad had it
so bad uh I had a hard time traveling my
family too because I might see some
Viejas
you here so you're dead at anxiety as
well oh my God so this is it sit in the
family thing we had a uh uh we were on a
cruise ship because my my parents
finally started making a little bit
that's the worst place for [ __ ]
with anxiety
dude we were in Cozumel I met a girl
um I was like 22 met this girl and she
had been drinking but her parents
weren't there and she got really [ __ ]
up she puked in the bathroom and then
all seems natural so far
[Laughter]
I mean just way out of my league I was
so happy and then uh her parents were
chewing up I hear
[Music]
my Dad shows up and I go hey Dad we
gotta deal with this like we can't what
do you mean you heard your dad as old
that's what happens when your boat's
about to like you got everybody out from
the cruise ship you better get back here
we're leaving
it's the warning like you get three and
now everybody make it back to the boat
so when you work on the boat we weren't
on the boat okay her parents were in
Cozumel no we just met this family at
the beach they said my daughter wants to
hang out with kids her age you guys
should take her into town and then she
started drinking with us my little
brother's 15 dancing on the table they
would put tequila bottles down and just
mark it with tape on the side how much
you drank like salt and pepper and
that's [ __ ] amazing so we are just
pouring tequila into each other's mouths
my brother's 15 dancing on the table man
and so everyone's wasted we were having
such a good time the entire bar moved
over to us people are partying hard then
we're
time to go so Al Madrigal with anxiety
here's that [ __ ] thing and I go Dad
we got to deal with the scroll our
parents your parents aren't here so we
can't just leave her and he goes
[ __ ] I'm not missing
[Laughter]
who goes I'm not missing that [ __ ]
boat
dude I don't matter that's what I said I
didn't go to Theory how magic was a
senior was a brutal
speaks Spanish to the cab driver puts
her in the cabin he goes do you know
where you live honey you could say the
words and he's like holds up her head
and she goes some condo complex and he
looks at the guy and in Spanish I asked
what he said and he goes in Spanish he
looks at the cab driver and he goes she
gets home anything happens to her I will
come here I will find you and I will
[ __ ] murder you do you understand
like that and okay man yeah I mean dude
it's super intense on but like my uncle
and my Dad were crazy
driver said yeah yeah no no [ __ ] Gil
said that you bring me some pocket
chorizo
[ __ ] right temperature and Papa's
mixed in I will [ __ ] murder you
that's right they were and just in an
airport but was your dad like that with
your dad was he like that or you saw
another side no no no listen [ __ ]
give me a chance to get to where she's
going out come back and I will [ __ ]
murder you yeah let's go let's go make
the bow like that's that's it that's it
you made the boat right oh yeah okay
good but like if I'm in an airport and
they start boarding and my wife goes I
want I need to go get a water and we've
been sitting there for an hour and a
half I lose my mind I was like or or I
gotta go I'm gonna go to the bathroom
I'm like we've been sitting here for a
[ __ ] hour and a half I don't
understand yeah so I think I think yeah
so any constraint of time I think gets
out yeah [ __ ] when I got married with
Anne you know she would be flying and
she'd go what time is the flight I said
7 30 she goes ah we should leave the
house at 6 15. i'm like [ __ ] how are we
gonna get to LAX and check it leave at 6
15. we'll make it there by 6 40. I was
like we're not gonna make it to LAX
that's [ __ ] 6 45 if you leave at 6 15
we're [ __ ] yeah and and that that's
that would drive me crazy yes so I would
say listen and I would go early but
she's not a morning person and now
you're trying to get get somebody that
doesn't get up to a [ __ ] one o'clock
in the afternoon to get up at 5 45 in
the morning it's not going to happen so
now we got a system
and what is that I take the family if we
go to LAX no I dropped a whole family
off I bring their bags I I go and I will
take the car to one of those quick Park
places
and then they make their slow ass way
through the airport and they're slow ass
like [ __ ] just times
and I show up you know in the bus and
then I have clear you don't have
anything and I got my backpack I'll take
my own bag so my wife doesn't have to
deal with it have you thought about
taking a car uh having a car come and
pick you up and take you but then I'd
have to go with them in the airport
oh so that's the whole point the whole
point you go through and you do your
slow that makes sense you don't have
your license ready you don't have like
all that yeah yeah that [ __ ] makes me
crazy like I know they're gonna look for
my license my license out like I got all
my [ __ ] ready to go right like so that's
what makes me nuts okay I'm just like
Clint Eastwood in Gran Torino all I ever
do is uh
I just look at her
that's all they do it's difficult to
travel with people though
I just throw it on autopilot dude I know
it's going to be terrible so I just like
I half leave will you fly up there to
Vancouver to see your not your
girlfriend no because I got to fly to
North Carolina and I'm already I'm
stressed about that this place my mom
got was built in 1880 it has not been
touched since and she just found
pictures in an attic of dead men naked
in the field with their names on the
back and then the word dead because
that's what this family did apparently
and I'm like
hey I'm [ __ ] going with you I gotta
go stay a week I'm terrified she's
talking about wolf spiders yeah snakes
in the in the in the rooms I'm like are
you what the [ __ ] have you seen pictures
of it has it is it in the place oh the
place they recorded Led Zeppelin No the
place is incredible and it looks
incredible but log cabin or something oh
yeah yeah it's like one big house and
then there's like six outbuildings and
it's on 12 acres in the woods it's like
it's beautiful but she's she's just she
she didn't tell any of us about what was
in it she didn't even tell my stepdad my
stepdad got there and you know the
master bedroom is eight inches lower
it's got to be raised there's all these
different things that need to be taken
care of that he wasn't aware of is it a
camp a Work Camp or something no it's
the same family who owned it from when
it got built owned it until now and they
finally got rid of it yeah man that's a
trip like what what's that in her though
what's what's that in her like to say
we're gonna move to this place dude I I
she
ARS ago Gunda had give me all the money
the manager who's supposed to do it did
nothing locked himself in the room and
so for like 15 minutes she had a gun to
her head and when that finished she was
like I'm done I gotta I can't live in a
city anymore so she has been trying to
run away ever since and North Carolina
is where her parents are from wow she
finally found the opportunity found the
perfect place and got that and now she's
going through all the stuff that these
people didn't take and she keeps finding
these pictures of like whoa literally
she's until she's like I pulled open
this box and there's three different
photos of a naked man dead in a field
which I would assume is the field there
on and then it's like
Jimmy Dickey dead
she's like I don't know I'm like what
the [ __ ] smallpox 1830 tables
I hate that [ __ ] I am terrified of
hillbillies and white people I swear to
God I really am I I am
terrified
all over the place
I would say away from a Cracker Barrel
interested in what's what's cooking in
the neighborhood or whatever the [ __ ]
Applebee's oh God but
um is it uh do you have any time of the
of the day that you feel clarity
like in the morning are you stressed the
Buddhist thing to do is the morning is
to is to lay there at least for five
minutes before you get out of bed and
contemplate
what's good and what's bad in your life
and what you would like to do and what
you would like to leave behind in the
first five minutes of your eyes opening
and it changes the way you think do you
don't get out of my bed I do it that's
for the chinos we didn't do that in my
Mexican house they're still there's way
more than us so they must be doing it
right
little thing behind you that little
noise then uh but but that's what they
do they they they can't the monk chose
to contemplate before you get out of bed
think about where you are in life
what you like what you don't like what
you would like to see happen and the
things that you would like to leave
behind and it's five minutes before he
said meditate for 11 but that's hard to
do yeah but but the contemplation don't
get out of bed until you've laid there
open or closed and just do it think
about it and then get only in the
morning not at night that's easy for you
to do because you're by yourself
yeah it's very difficult if you've got
the wife next to you saying hey honey or
hey what about five minutes your wife do
an impression of your wife so she can
hear it on the pocket
she doesn't
she doesn't listen to him because she's
getting more in trouble yeah she doesn't
listen too much because she's a she
knows who I am you're saying you guys
talk first thing in the morning yeah
right off the bat yeah I wake up at
least an hour before her and I'll just
get on the iPad I won't wake her up
won't turn in so just put my ear pain
and I'd get on the iPad when she gets up
then it's good morning and good morning
and you want coffee yeah I love coffee
do you think that's over stimulation in
the morning like to start like that I'd
say do the five minutes I'll try the
food no pot no iPad no I believe it I'll
try it or stimulation first thing I do
is grab my phone that's that is
apparently like the absolute worst thing
yeah because you're taking in yeah stuff
not putting stuff out there yeah you
also you have a seance room in your
house though so you already got some
stuff attached to you yeah
told him not to go in and ask questions
the first thing he does is walk in and
start asking questions tell everybody
what happened to uh all right so I do
the paragordo podcast
um live hilarious so funny
um like we had a bunch of what were the
questions they were asking you well the
Latinas that took the mic and got up and
spoke and talked about their
Supernatural experiences it was one of
the funniest [ __ ] things I've ever
seen in my life everyone had to tell you
where they were living at the time so it
was like I was living in Norwalk and uh
then oh you did it right there yeah
I was living in Rosemead at the time and
so uh and it was very funny so
Mo I'm telling Momo about the Seance
room because they used to do Ouija board
the house was built in 1958 and in the
60s they would do Ouija board in this
room
and so it had this chained bench in
there it was a funky room wormwood and
they also had like their Wine Cellar in
there but it is sunken down with cement
floors it's creepy and that's where I'd
go uh find rats or anything like that
that's where they would sneak in and so
what
scared to death of rats
really yeah you know how many dead
bodies you've seen in your system
seriously you ever seen that cartoon
where the elephant jumps up on the table
because there's a rat
so I killed I was so proud of my son too
because we had the last rat that we
killed
um it was it got caught in a glue trap
but it was still alive and I got Lorenzo
I'm sorry everybody underneath your man
up I needed to hold it down with this
broom I'm gonna get a hammer and I'm
gonna bludgeoned this thing real quick
and you wonder where the anxiety comes
from
[Applause]
lift it up every once in a while it
sounded like the right the rat was like
come on man I got kids please
started hammering rats shut up
so I had to go and give it a little
whack but anyway I go in there I'm like
this is all [ __ ] Momo was telling me
that that's easy released a bunch of
spirits in there so I go in there shut
the door shut off the lights I'm
standing there in the pitch dark and I
go so is anybody here huh show yourself
and I swear to God it was like
you never watched a horror film before
my hair and I I thought it was just
because I was scared when it was colder
in there but I swear to God the hair on
my arms stood up straight
Like That Just Junk I've done the pair
of paranormal uh paragorda podcast but
only a Mobile's Place uh I've been up on
stage with them up there at the uh well
I he packed it out he killed and they
did a thing on Aliens it was and he had
AJ up there with him he knows what he's
talking about and they did stuff and he
says I want to ask you some questions
you come on stage will you do it see
I'll do it so here are the questions I
want to ask I said don't tell me the
questions ask them up there I'll answer
and so he said do you believe in aliens
I said no
and he said why don't you I said I don't
look up I don't give a [ __ ] what's going
on up there but not my world stay down
here
and he's okay he says what would you do
if there was an alien in your house
coming down coming down the hallway
you're the only one there what are you
gonna do I said I'm gonna get the [ __ ]
out go out my window I said I ain't
white I'm not going to go up there and
say hey what are you doing here who are
you why I'm get the [ __ ] out I'm I ain't
gonna fight that thing
he says okay well there's an alien in
there and all of a sudden you're getting
a [ __ ] right there you're by yourself
what are you gonna do I said well I got
a couple of minutes of spare you know
there's no need to be in a hurry and so
I I've done that [ __ ] with him and it
was fun it was hilarious yeah really
funny
um but you never had a uh you ever
thought that Richard Ramirez has come
back to you anywhere never felt this
presence no I had a nightmare bottom
once but that was that was it was it a
vivid nightmare like he was in in body
yeah and it's I was never had one of
those it's it's a very rare uh dream
where it's almost like if we were
sitting here talking and you're talking
to Richard Ramirez we were we we were
going to visit you I'm transporting him
we're in a courthouse we got him and now
it's just me and him and I said you know
the drill don't [ __ ] around you know
because I'll I'll [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
blast you I won't mess around I said
yeah yeah I'm not and then we got in
this we got in this [ __ ] elevator
almost when he started [ __ ] around
and I go to blast him and the [ __ ]
bullets with a plank plink and he's
[ __ ] laughing at me
then it turned into an instant nightmare
then I woke up then I got scared I came
to be he came to visit you I pissed in
my pants
he you did no but you know what he came
to visit you his Spirit came to visit
yeah [ __ ] him that was his unfinished
business
that's an unfinished business and him
and I the reason maybe maybe he did
maybe you guys [ __ ] around with each
other but we got along we got a lot of
kidding back each other back yeah he he
called me Gill I called him we had
respect for you right yeah yeah he
didn't treat you like a punk or didn't
disrespect you no he liked me yeah and
so Authority see like you know
and I never treated him bad no never
said anything about him he respected
that even though he was he was a you
know just a murderer serial killer he
had respect for you because everyone
else had not respected him you saw how
they treated him and then you treat him
with respect you gravitated toward that
he came to say goodbye to you yeah okay
see ya
has your mom moved into the house yet
yeah she just went back today has she
seen anything any more pictures she
there's no pictures as of now she came
for a week and then she talked to Momo
about it and Momo started talking about
how oh you know there's there's uh
there's grapes there's Graves there
they're unmarked somebody who ever lived
there took the took the markers off the
graves and my mom was like okay well
where are they she's like he's like you
got Wells and she's like yeah I got
three he's like there's one behind the
house checking around there I'm like
Jesus Christ my mom
spends spends all day watching Ghost
Hunters and all that stuff she's begging
for it she was asking a question she's
like I don't know she's so open to
seeing ghosts and feeling that but she
never really has and so she wonders why
that's never worked for her did you talk
to him about clearing it because he has
a specific way he doesn't want to clear
it she wants to have me no she uh she
straight up would love if these ghosts
came she wants to make sat down and
spoke with her Momo get your ticket
she wants she wants to make contact with
that she wants to contact them she wants
any contact whatsoever she's always
looking for medium she's always doing
that she's always right even when she
found a good medium her dad came but
talked to the other sisters and not her
all that kind of stuff so she's like I
don't know if because she's so open to
it and aware that like she wants it to
happen that that's why it's not
happening but do you think if I went
back there put a sheet over me she'd
think I was just a fat ghost
um that might be dangerous because I
don't know what she's trying to do with
the ghosts
so really really depends uh I want to
show you guys uh you know how my mouse
is this fine is this the it's one of
them the orbs
no the orbs are one thing but
this stuff let me see where is it look
what I just got from the guy we're
talking about
we were just talking about that from
Momo he's telling me he sent me a promo
for Tommy's chili cheese fries
[Laughter]
I'm supposed to see him saturday night I
was just too goddamn tired
see what I mean that's no accident here
could
tell him I said hi
there is no accident by the way that we
were talking about him and he he's
texting
yeah
I was supposed to go see him saturday
night he had a show but I just flew in
from Seattle and I just got over this
thing if you watch the last podcast I
hear about it George is making fun of me
because I was losing blood and coming
out my coming out my ass he made a song
about it was this the ulcer huh was it
ulcer yeah you had an ulcer or I had an
ulcerer I've had one bleeding ulcer this
one just opened up again and then I had
some palps that were bleeding on the
inside but everything come out negative
everything's good I'm back together but
I told Momo you know they told me it was
going to take two months because I lost
so much bloody you know try to build it
back up
and I said I just flew in from Seattle
I'm tired
um so I couldn't make it to a show
Saturday Ryan says there's a Paranormal
app
on
Tick Tock and
see this
that's not my finger
nor is it it's fuzzy okay what is it
it's a paranormal thing that was in my
bedroom
so Mayan says there's a paranormal this
is not my finger and watch how fast it
takes off
watch how fast it takes off
what this is in my bedroom
it even makes no
that's in front it's right in front of
me
it looks like your thumb moving out of
the way of the camera
it's not my thumb what's the the glare
in between it that's that's the the you
The Tick Tock paranormal locating it
and then showing it and then it kicks
off to the left so we did that on the
show and that was that was a real thing
that actually yes and then I'm thinking
about putting a gate
in part of my house and I took a picture
of the wall and
this image came out at the bottom
which is
it was during the day it was in front of
me it's not my finger it's not my finger
because it's round like the one that was
in the room
so what do you think it is I think it's
something that's following that's with
me I don't think do you think it's
somebody specific is it yeah I don't
know if it's specific but I don't think
it's a bad thing it's on my fingers
and it's fuzzy
yeah no that's a
H there's no face it's not my nail
it's not my nail no we all have somebody
going around with us do you think
um I do I I now I'll tell you right now
I'll be honest with you
I love George he's a friend I love what
I'm doing
but you ain't gonna see me around
Jordan's house late at night
I know because of all the stuff that
you've been
the last few shows we've talked about
the Paranormal stuff uh I swear
couple of you know just plays with your
mind I I don't
I don't buy it
but just this week all of a sudden I'm
laying there next to my wife for
watching TV and the door closes by
itself
and my wife just went
she looked at me and I looked back at
her
and I and I just said
good night Vera
that was my mother-in-law she lived with
us for six years before she passed away
she was right I said good night Vera and
but I I there was no explanation I
started laughing you know about the
house I grew up in I mean we didn't grow
up together
I thought I told you the story so we
don't talk at work you're talking you
only talk to the [ __ ] camera people
so
my the house I grew up in was building
that's a part of like you want everybody
to like you I think I think that's part
of it it's got to be yeah
but I I do genuinely like talking to all
the people like people yeah
you're the same way right yeah I I do I
I like talking people did I know the
prop girl the prop girl prop uh lady uh
has a son who's 10.
all right she misses him uh anyway
so I grew up in a house that was built
in in San Francisco in the sunset
District it was built in 1907 it was
built by a famous shipbuilder he built
that house for his daughter he also was
a famous architect
um if you go to my house in any of the
earthquakes he built it
it's never survive the earthquake
nothing moved picture was slightly
crooked because he built this thing for
his daughter and is built like a ship so
it just beams everywhere there's a guy
it doesn't work nice Victorian two
bedroom one bath and
um he built all the Alameda courthouses
everything like that he was dying
he uh committed suicide put a gun in his
mouth in our living room wow
um and killed himself we have a picture
that I grew up with of him and his bio
when you go into the upstairs in the
hallway me and my little brothers were
latchkey kids we were my both my parents
worked full-time jobs and we took care
of I took care of my two little brothers
Ian Tatam I heard [ __ ]
non-stop it was him
yeah you guys had the picture there you
probably felt you probably felt safe
there walking up the stairs he still
wanted to live there you didn't want to
go he didn't want to go he had some bad
health
walking around my brothers my brother
was three we had little knives we would
go down and inspect the garage
steak knife
walking around but we hear [ __ ]
constantly when I was in college lived
in the house and
um fell asleep I would feel something
late I was telling Momo this he said it
was uh he had a term for it but I would
feel something lay down on me almost
every single night wow
and like snuggle see then I just don't
sleep there anymore yeah thank you it
only takes me for me and you guys
weren't gonna move you weren't going to
say like all these places you're still
on the house we still have it because my
brother lives there
no
no
really have you know there's something
that says power suggestion uh because I
remember we'd
on a perimeter in Vietnam you'd sit
there and say hey get a new guy fngs hey
see that see what hey look at the bush
it's moving
and then Light It Up just start and all
of a sudden flares it starts shooting up
in here and there was nothing there
because all you do with power suggestion
before you know it you got them
convinced that it's really there
and it was easy to do you
power suggestion do a lot of a lot of
things I ain't
and and if I can't can if I can't
control that
this Mexicans out of there [ __ ] I ain't
staying there
if I can't fight it no no of course but
I mean we're not I mean it's interesting
because your mom purposely found I mean
I mean I haven't seen the place but
it's it's fascinating it would be
fascinating to her especially if
somebody
that was at home but still if you went
somewhere you would engage with everyone
but when you were home now you now you
have something that can Captivate you
yeah I could never buy you know it's
like buying a piece of property that's
right next to the cemetery or they cut
out a piece of lot you know this part of
the cemetery now you get to live there
and I say oh no I I don't know if this
shit's real or not real but I ain't
gonna test it if she had the money to do
it she would buy
an asylum or something like that that is
very well known to be haunted she
wouldn't immediately do it is that after
the bank bank uh bank robbery
like that's been over the past five
years she wants to die maybe dude I
don't know supposed to be excited she's
been trying to get through she's been
trying for like three years she's like I
need you to make a pitch I want to do
ghost grannies I want to do a show ghost
granny so that they send me everywhere
and I can go stay the night in you know
castles and things like that and just
see what it's like
okay
you and I said most granny not me you
and his mom team up and you guys are
ghost grannies they go and look I'd be
the one that's [ __ ] on the camera
she wants to If For What It's Worth you
and her would be battling because she
shits herself more than anybody I've
ever met so that's great it's disgusting
it's absolutely disgusting but we're an
open book no mobile keeps telling me hey
let's go I want you to go with me on one
of these to go look go to the Queen Mary
and George is even I was even concerned
I stood at the Queen Mary one time and I
didn't like staying there
I have after you know you read about it
you hear about it and you hear [ __ ] at
night at the [ __ ] you know what you
should go to equipment because there's a
little boy ghost at least churros at
everybody's door
but in my in my house so I live alone in
that big ass that my that house
because whatever the house and there and
there's
even last night there's things in there
that
uh as I was going to sleep
like you hear things are just like
so what do you do yeah you say good
night everybody no I can't I don't talk
to him you don't ever acknowledge they
told me not to because I would bring
that time that I was like a banging and
[ __ ] that was I was tough but but once
you bring out Congo's and start playing
them I'll play some cards and titles so
so the the I was born in General
Hospital down you know St George day
April 23rd like my mom wanted to name me
after somebody else and then my
grandmother said what's the day today
and the nurse said that's April 23rd St
George day
that's the same St George so I was in
escrow on another house in in war in
where I live and then that fell through
and then I found this house and in the
fireplace it was kind of soot and I had
the guy the contractor clean it out and
it was a St George tile from the 20s in
my fireplace wow that's a little
serendipitous like right and you the you
know people don't realize there's some
things you see like that we're talking
about more money text like some things
are meant to be so it tells you that in
the universe things are already
predetermined and things are just going
to happen and you just have to go and do
what you do if you say to somebody that
says like you know you hear people that
say oh I'm supposed to be on that flight
I decided not to go take another flight
and then you know those things happen
all the time but I just think in our
life that these things are all
kind of predetermined I mean doing a
show with Mayan I never would have
thought of it but then being there I'm
not
what would you say I'm not
um surprised by it like I'm not like wow
this is really I mean it really is
something do you just chalk it all up to
fate essentially I just think it's just
I never we never talked about it we
never should like oh you know when you
grow up you know what we'll do a show
together never considered it and
although we go there and we do all the
stuff that we've done already like 12
times
I don't think of it and is unusual yeah
let's think if it's not it's in the
thing and she did her work too she's not
like you know she was 12 and said I want
to be a comedian then didn't work until
she was 25 you know she she's done her
work when we first met she was in
Chicago uh when you were telling me how
she was doing improv stuff Second City
yep
so she put in the she but also I'm
surprised that uh I'm a little surprised
at how much
all the things that she struggles with
you know I'm not I don't I'm just
surprised by
but also you know I think that uh let me
see be very careful here also think that
her both of us are very our parents are
very different
so you know it's like you have you have
a you have somebody that's afraid of
water and then you have someone that's
not afraid to of water it's like when
you split time it's you're going to
inherit some traits of something let's
hear what her boyfriend what are the
problems husband boyfriend her husband
no but I mean overall in the thing like
she doesn't
um you see a little bit of it when she
gets tired but you know of things that
are new to somebody right you're wearing
your emotions on your sleeve
oh yep
you know uh she'd say uh she's a champ
and uh it is uh it's a it's a weird gig
man just but you did call it I mean we
did a pilot three years ago and he he
called it and he said this is going to
happen for sure so there's that like uh
yeah it's uh it's interesting hey man I
want you to play my best friend yeah you
know I got this thing at Fox
It's Not Unusual
um you know I will say this
what you're trying with the bring it
back to the anxiety thing and the fact
that I just talked to a therapist for
the first time and I'm 51 years old like
I do encourage anybody listening who
wants this because you did it before
you've done it for 22 I've talked to a
guy for 22 years
I really I I did it
um I uh I I should have done it sooner
and I would encourage my son to do it
but my son has the same attitude already
the Gil has he's like ah of course
because I mean everybody has that
attitude because it hasn't been anything
that's been familiarized to them so of
course right exactly it's the it's the
idea of well I already know enough or
you know I've got people my friends
listing off all of his friends that
would do it have done therapy and he
goes he goes tells my wife he goes so no
so far you're not making a great case
because he goes those are all dorks
I don't think I've had the time to
really you know because I was 17 went
into the army ended up in Vietnam come
out of Vietnam started college then I
became a cop right away so it was always
very structured now and the wife was
very independent I mean she ran the
house three kids she ran the house she's
never worked and so now I never had time
to think about this [ __ ] because I was
always the man you got a problem come to
me you know let's do it so I never had
time in order to ever think but you've
seen some crazy [ __ ] the amount of dead
bodies you've seen yeah that bodies you
know I don't care if they're mangled
they look ugly they do this to you and
to
most of the population they're ugly
there but to me
they tell a story it's scientific you
know I I don't see the blood guts and
Gore you see blood guts and Gore
if you were to see a man out in the
middle of the street decapitated and
he's got ten thousand dollars in his
hand and his body's strewn about because
a 10 ton of my truck has just run him
over
you're gonna go up there and say oh God
look at the blood the guts his head hey
first thing I'll see is ten thousand
dollars in his hand
and that's why you did what you did yeah
so people could do that and now you know
when I when I see something I'm looking
at okay blood spatterings here blood
spatterings there which was the first
shot which how did he die you know so
I'm looking at other things
just like a gynecologist
when he sees as many vaginal cavities as
he does on a daily basis it's nothing to
him but let him get with his girlfriend
at night and all of a sudden he's
breathing heavy
so that that's what it is this is all
just very scientific kind of like a
doctor looking at this stuff doesn't so
that never you don't you're not haunted
by that you don't no not at all no not
at all that doesn't and there's not one
case or anything that you keep thinking
about the dead body or anything no not
that but more emotional stuff than
anything else a lady a quadruple
homicide where she watched her husband
her brother and two nephews get murdered
right in front of her she got raped not
once but twice uh by the guy that
kidnapped her uh that's traumatizing
then she had a she had to talk to me
a male that doesn't know anything about
or just met her and now she's telling me
this stuff and she was traumatic she'd
break down hysterically crying I found
out she got raped okay stop depressed
let's get her to the hospital let's get
her examined now let's go over what we
didn't try to find out and so that case
today
that I was with her most of the night I
found her probably about nine o'clock at
night and we brought her back to the
station about two in the afternoon the
next day
and I couldn't even talk to go explain
to her family
what was going on I had my partner who
was a boot rookie but she was a female I
said and yeah no she didn't had uh you
know I was asking yeah I know you do she
did have nice everything else fair and
and she uh she was fluent in Spanish
because it was all Hispanic survives you
I couldn't even talk
it traumatized me that much it was it
was an ugly scene but not because of
what I saw it was the human element it
was a human element that that bothered
me more than anything else but you know
I think part of that is I think it may
be might be different now if someone was
a victim of a violent crime that their
first Contact isn't somebody who's not
trained like somebody who's a police
officer that would say the wrong thing
he made the the first respondent police
get out of bed today you know like if I
can break the ice hey that Patrol cop
that goes out there and sees this stuff
you know he may have nightmares they may
have ugly thing but not me they do but I
mean and I think it's different now like
where if a kid was abandoned that you
know a cop with a female cop would take
the kid that was their reaching out to
you know make the kitchen sure
comfortable exactly and now it's
probably somebody who's a uh um a
pervert no yeah
so after seeing so Much Death and things
like that do you react differently to
somebody close to you passes away or
anything like that does it no does it
not register the same or is it like no
like if someone is being attacked you
get a boner
only advice only if I see a girl with
big Peppers that's what we can just buy
a car how about a cup
all right well I'm not sure if we if we
talked about anything that we had
planned to talk about but it was fun I
think it was actually pretty great we
talked about anxiety a lot and that's
what our episode this week is about yeah
I think anxiety is hilarious yeah that
was a good one too yeah oh this is a
great episode yeah I'm just happy I'm
flattered I I got to go to your you went
with the taping yeah I was at the taping
for your first show oh were you yeah and
so I got and now I'm sitting here with
you guys I'm I'm glad that was what you
when you knew oh you're talking about
that one where you get to walk out and
you wave to the audience and we did our
Curtain Call so you walk out at the end
and I'll never forget there were two
kids up at the top right and they were
losing their [ __ ] and that's when I was
like oh wow this is special like this is
amazing and um I can't wait for
everybody to see all of these episodes
because they're sophisticated they're
silly they're [ __ ] they talk about
real [ __ ] and here's nothing so yeah
tell a friend you're listening to this
podcast obviously you're a fan of George
and Gil and all the people he has on but
this show is different so spread the
word it's legitimate oh it's a good show
everybody uh my family they know I'm
close to Jordan but family friends I
talk about it because I I push it eight
be sure yeah Prime Time Channel 4 NBC
and they did I talked to them I've
contacted people
not one negative uh thing about it
everybody likes it so and that was the
pilot
yeah all right thank you man let's go
thank you uh every Friday night at eight
next day streaming on peacock love it